[Musique]
il a écouté tout d'abord bonsoir j'ai
l'impression d'avoir joué à marseille
des applaudissements étaient
chaleureuses écoutez je dois parler du
thème de tout réinventer et beaucoup et
je pense que la première des choses
pourrait inventer c'est prendre
conscience de ce qui est et en parlant
de prendre conscience de ce qui est je
vais vous montrer une carte que je
montre aux étudiants dans les écoles
est ce que vous voyez cette carte un
règle générale les enfants me demandent
de tourner cette carte parce que il
semblerait que ce soit à l'envers
j'espère que j'essaie d'expliquer aux
enfants que les cartes traditionnelles
que nous connaissons où il y à l'europe
au centre
en fait c'est une carte qui ne
respectent pas les vrais proportions
selon les continents
je ne sais pas si vous saviez c'est à
dire que l'europe est au centre
l'europe est agrandie l'amérique du nord
est a grandi on se demande pourquoi
et donc l'idée c'est dire aux enfants
toujours il faut pouvoir regarder les
choses dans plusieurs directions et sur
cette carte
effectivement vous voyez là la taille
réelle de l'afrique et la taille réelle
de la france d'ailleurs quand j'ai
montré cette carte à mon fils mon fils
m'a dit papa tu as cartel est pas bonne
il n'y a pas la france donc en fait
c'est très important effectivement qu'on
puisse se questionner de regarder les
choses dans plusieurs directions pour
être le plus libre possible
pourquoi je vous parle de libre de la
liberté parce que en fait chacun de nous
ici
parfois on ne se rend pas compte en fait
que nous ne sommes pas libres nous
sommes enfermés dans des catégories et
je dois fouet qui elle catégorie qui
n'est pas très amusante
c'est la catégorie noir pourquoi je suis
né aux antilles en 1972 j'arrive à paris
à l'âge de 9 ans et à l'école on me fait
comprendre que j'étais noir et j'ai
compris qu'être noir c'était est revu de
façon inférieur
donc j'ai essayé de comprendre le
pourquoi et ma maman m'a dit que c'était
comme ça les gens étaient racistes va
pas changer
et donc j'ai essayé de comprendre le
pourquoi du racisme en fait j'ai compris
que c'était culturel que ses enfants de
couleur blanche qui me disait que
j'étais inférieur c'est parce que
culturellement ils ont été éduqués à se
penser supérieur parce qu'ils avaient
cette couleur là et toutes ont
longuement les naissances j'ai essayé de
comprendre de me dire voilà comment je
pourrais parler du racisme de façon
intelligente pour faire changer les
choses
réinventer la façon d'aborder ce sujet
et je me suis dit tiens ce serait
intéressant de questionner les
catégories tu dominante
parce que très souvent lorsqu'on parle
est qu'on parle du racisme du sexisme
l'homophobie très souvent se focalise
sur les personnes qui sont discriminés
et je me dis tiens je vais inverser les
choses pour dire lorsqu'on parle du
sexisme
il est important de questionner qu'est
ce que c'est être un homme parce
qu'effectivement en règle générale il ya
beaucoup de définitions sur ce qu'est
être une femme très souvent c'est
inférieur aux hommes et donc l'idée
m'est venue de toujours de questionner
mon entourage par exemple vous je vous
raconte une expérience j'étais dans un
ministère un jour en faisait un tour de
table et je dois présenter le travail
que je fais j'ai dit voilà je travaille
sur les discriminations india bon j mais
par exemple dans cette dans cette salle
c'est très intéressant parce que
lorsqu'on regarde les femmes et là le
président de l'assemblée me dit ah oui
vous avez raison monsieur turin il ya
très peu de femmes j non c'est pas vrai
le vrai problème c'est qu'il ya trop
d'hommes en est là tous les hommes on
regarde avec un oeil
je crois que s'il avait un pistolet gt
mais en fait c
mettre en exergue les personnes qui
profitent des discriminations parce que
très souvent lorsqu'on parle de
discrimination ne voit jamais ce qui
profilent des discriminations est alors
pareil
j'essaie de dire voilà ces enfants de
couleur blanche qui me disent que je
suis loin inférieur est-ce qu'ils ont
conscience qu'être blanc c'est être
dominant dans la société
je pense que ses enfants ne le savent
pas ils reproduisent des schémas de
pensée et donc un jour je me dis mais
comment faire je me dis tiens je vais
appeler mon meilleur ami d'enfance je
prends mon téléphone jeudi à l'offrant
que dix mois
j'aimerais savoir est ce que tu as le
sentiment d'être blanc d'image je
comprends pas gilbert franck je suis
noir il me dit bah ouais je dis mais si
je suis noir thé quoi bein je suis
normal
en fait c'est très intéressant c'est
pour ça que je dis que il faut
questionner les normes
il faut questionner la norme et je pense
qu'effectivement si nous prenons
l'habitude de questionner ce qui se
pense dominant peut-être que nous
pourrons changer les discriminations
parce qu'encore une fois très souvent
ceux qui sont dans une situation de
domination se pensent beaucoup plus
légitime que les autres parce que c'est
une question de légitimité c'est pour ça
que je dis que très souvent nous sommes
enfermés dans des catégories
nous ne sommes pas libres ici il ya
peut-être des gens qui sont fermés dans
des catégories selon la religion et vous
allez être éduqué dans une certaine
religion et ce qui est très intéressant
avec la religion c'est que lorsque vous
êtes enfant très souvent vous allez
déterminer déjà votre compagnon ou votre
compagne
sachant que vous allez chercher
quelqu'un tu auras la même religion que
vous et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant quand je dis dans la liberté
de pensée les dominants très souvent
vont vouloir décider pour les autres
c'est à dire que historiquement les
hommes pensent que c'est à eux de
décider à savoir ce que les femmes ont
le droit de faire ou non les hétéros
vont penser que c'est tout à fait normal
de décider à savoir ce que les personnes
homosexuelles ont le droit de faire ou
non dans une société est historiquement
les personnes blanches pense qu'ils font
il faut que ce soit eux qui décident à
savoir ce que les personnes d'une autre
couleur que peut faire ou non et donc en
fait si on ne prend pas conscience que
chacun de nous nous sommes dans des
catégories
eh bien on peut pas réinventer la
société et l'idée pour moi de quand je
parle de réinventer la société sa part
un concept très simple c'est à dire que
chacun puisse voir l'autre comme un être
unique et voir l'autre comme un être
humain avant tout mais c'est un concept
qui est extrêmement simple mais très
souvent on réfléchit à travers nos
catégories de génération en génération
et lorsque vous voulez sortir de ces
catégories
vous êtes mal vu parce que tout d'un
coup vous questionner la catégorie vous
voulez être libre et tout d'un coup il
ya un conflit de loyauté et certaines
personnes vous rattrape donc vous êtes
capable de vous enfermer dans vos
nationalité vous êtes capable de vous
enfermer dans vos origines dans les
religions
vous êtes capable de vous enfermer dans
votre continent c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire il y aurait
nous et eux nous et 2 et lieux ne sont
pas aussi légitime que nous et donc
l'idée c'est effectivement de
questionner la carte que nous avons qu
on avons que nous avons vu au début c
est ce que cette terre est légitime pour
tout le monde
est ce que tout un chacun de nous nous
sommes légitimes
est-ce que nous pouvons nous questionner
se dire que peut-être dans le futur il
faut réinventer un concept qui serait le
partage c'est pas mal concède le partage
c'est simple la solidarité parce que
effectivement pendant très longtemps
certains se sont crus légitime au monde
et on pensait et on pensait que le monde
leur appartenait il ya un petit jeu que
je fais avec les enfants bon vous êtes
des adultes en même temps des enfants
aussi
donc vous allez réfléchir à la question
est ce que vous connaissez christophe
colomb vous connaissez que les sauf
quand il ya un monsieur qui fait comme
ça bien sûr c'est qu'ils christophe
colomb
un explorateur la petit à petit il se
lance pas en règle générale les enfants
me disent monsieur thuram c'est celui
qui a découvert l'amérique à je leur dis
ah ouais c'est intéressant ça il a
découvert l'amérique est donc en règle
générale j attendais je sors de la
classe et je reviens dans la classe en
disant j'ai découvert la classe ben non
je dis mais pourquoi on était déjà là
j'y mets ça intéressant parce que quand
christophe colomb arrive dans les
amériques à 80 millions d'habitants et
j'entends away
hélas les profs se cache un petit peu en
fait c'est ça réinventer les choses
c'est comment chacun de nous on
construit notre imaginaire collectif
quelle est l'histoire qu'on nous raconte
est-ce que parfois on ne se pense pas
plus légitime que les autres et je pense
que chacun de nous mesdames messieurs
nous sommes totalement légitime et il
faut le répéter
chacun de nous nous avons notre place
dans ce monde
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]